[Music]
on this friday night a very different
kind of canada day
the parties
the pledge for reconciliation we must
all
work together and the protests
a canadian fighting for ukraine's
freedom it's crap here
it's it's no fun and everybody suffers
why he feels he needs to be on the front
lines
china's government tightens its grip on
hong kong 25 years after handover this
is a city that is no longer recognizable
the disappearance of democracy and
dissent and laboring less but getting
more our workforce is happier the
winning formula of a four day work week
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight
colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us for
the first time in two years the federal
canada day ceremony was held in person
in the nation's capital without public
health restrictions but with more
protesters than in past years the
celebration is usually on parliament
hill but this year the majority of
events have been moved to lebreton flats
a 20-minute walk west of the hill
because ongoing construction at the
center block has reduced lawn space our
chief political correspondent david
aiken is there and david for the first
time ever canada day festivities were
presided over by an indigenous governor
general indeed colleen the ceremony
celebrated indigenous cultures but it
also recognized that at 155 years old
canada still has a long way to go when
it comes to reconciliation
[Music]
the day started with an anishinabe water
ceremony welcome to our unseated
unsurrendered algonquin and nishinobig
territory and then it was on to the
day's main event relocated to le breton
flats from nearby parliament hill a
relocation that was just fine with
co-host and comedian sean majumder we're
a few blocks away at the bretton flats
park which i'm happy about because after
a few two years of the pandemic i'm way
better on the flats than i am the hills
there were performances from
newfoundland's kelly loader
[Music]
[Music]
and some bongra from yukon social media
star gurdeep prandtl
[Applause]
and of course there were speeches hello
everyone happy canada day
trudeau talked about the symbolism of
the maple leaf with a thinly veiled
reference to the so-called freedom
convoy protesters who often wrap
themselves in a flag being able
to be who you are
to love whom you love to chase your
dreams to live without fear this is the
freedom the maple leaf represents
both trudeau and especially governor
general simon also said canada day is a
time to recommit to reconciliation we
must all
work together
to walk the road of reconciliation
and healing
it begins
with understanding and respect
it is a smaller crowd this year there
was about four thousand people here when
you might get ten times that many up
there on parliament hill colleen
david aiken in ottawa today thanks david
police in downtown ottawa were ready
today expecting anti-government
protesters to make their way to
parliament hill
for most of the day there wasn't much to
see very different from the truck convoy
this past winter but as the afternoon
wore on the protest crowd grew our
abigail beeman has more
midday security lineups to get onto a
mostly empty parliament hill the
majority of the hundreds of people along
ottawa's wellington street friday came
to celebrate canada day it feels great i
i like being in canada
it's just fun being here we're excited
to be here at parliament hill while a
small contingent among them were
anti-mandate so-called freedom
protesters overlapping with february's
original convoy crowd we didn't give up
we didn't give in
we are still here and we're still proud
to be here we're fighting for our rights
the government's taking away one step at
a time police promising to take a harder
line this time around tensions flaring
by mid afternoon this group pressing in
as bylaw officers told a few protesters
they couldn't set up a table here they
say they eventually took it down we're
getting signatures on a on a declaration
to the joint committee asking them to
recommend trudeau for for treason to
charge treason the protest movement
doesn't have one clear leader or even
one clear group and in the days leading
up to canada day plans kept changing
police got wind of an event planned for
here on the lawn of the supreme court
and then these fences went up think that
the mandates have been kicked down but
they're still there one group planned
and then cancelled a kids picnic in a
nearby park but a small contingent
including maxine bernier still showed up
the government
may go ahead with the mandates this fall
a significantly bigger crowd in the late
afternoon on a march through downtown
streets the route kept changing with
police keeping close watch things are
going in the right direction but if they
try this again in the fall we're going
to be out double the size by evening
police had not yet released any
information as to whether there were any
arrests friday after four people were
arrested at the war memorial thursday
night police say there was a
confrontation and one officer was choked
colleen abigail beeman in ottawa abigail
thank you on this canada day some
canadians have chosen to leave the
safety of their homes to risk their
lives overseas for the freedoms we enjoy
here when russia invaded ukraine in
february thousands volunteered to join
an international legion to operate as
part of ukraine's military among them a
calgary trucker who said he wanted to do
more than just talk shawn o'shea met up
with him on a brief break from the front
line
matthew mcgill is a long way from home
this canada day i felt that i needed to
do
whatever i could do
to help with the fight mcgill is 49 a
father of two and a brand new
grandfather but instead of relaxing with
his family this holiday he's quite
literally in the trenches trying to stop
russians from advancing here in ukraine
i have skills that i thought would be
useful here signal skills honed as a
canadian forces member in the 90s canada
has trained over thirty thousand
ukrainian forces and part of their
ability to work in the field is a
tribute to canadian training in four
months here mcgill says his perspective
is forever changed driven by scenes like
these how horrible the russians are in
their treatment of the ukrainian
civilians
has made me feel more strongly about the
need for me to be here monday's attack
on the shopping center is russia's most
blatant killing of civilians so far 18
dead dozens more injured days later
they're still cleaning up still finding
body parts
then on thursday night russia sent two
more cruise missiles into an apartment
building near the port city of odessa
officials say 20 or more were killed
russia has stepped up its missile
strikes in central and eastern areas of
ukraine in the last two weeks mcgill
told us he's seen fellow soldiers die on
the front line being hit by missiles and
artillery very close is something that
will change everybody but he remains
here by choice it's very canadian to
work for the piece of the world it's
very canadian to sacrifice your life in
order to defend a foreign country
against aggression it's very canadian to
not think of your own welfare but to
think of the broader welfare mcgill
spent a month training with ukrainians
before taking up his post he says they
still need more arm support on the
ground
and when i asked him if he had a message
in mind on a day many of us are
reflecting on canadian values he shared
this just be grateful
that we don't have war in canada
because it's
it's crap here
it's
no fun
and everybody suffers so just be very
thankful that in canada we we have peace
and
we're not under threat it's a
perspective forged by extraordinary
courage and determination that hits
close to home even from a world away
shawn o'shea global news kremenchuk
ukraine
the trial of a highly decorated american
basketball star facing drug smuggling
charges got underway in russia today the
case against brittany griner is thought
to be politically motivated she was
charged the week before the kremlin's
full-scale invasion of ukraine and given
the current political climate a guilty
verdict is expected it could mean 10
years locked up inside a penal colony as
crystal gomencing reports that's fueling
the fight for her freedom
whisked into a russian courtroom away
from western cameras and journalists
seeing brittany griner for just seconds
quashed any hopes of getting a sense of
the 31 year old's mental state as she
goes on trial in russia
it's alleged the two-time olympic gold
medalists smuggled narcotics into the
country
task the russian state media
organization which was allowed to
observe the proceedings reported the
court was told griner had two vape
cartridges containing small amounts of
hash oil in her bags upon arriving in
russia in february i did have the
opportunity to speak with miss greiner
in the courtroom she is doing as well as
can be expected in these difficult
circumstances and she asked me to convey
that she is in good spirits and is
keeping up the faith
the women's national basketball players
association posted its support of griner
who went to russia to play for an
international team
noting the
134 days she spent in detention
efforts to secure her release are
ongoing last month advocates penned a
letter to joe biden and kamala harris we
now urge you to make a deal to get
brittany back home to america
immediately and safely it was
undersigned by dozens of organizations
and individuals
u.s relations with the kremlin are fraud
and american officials widely consider
greiner's detention political
at this point a guilty verdict is
assumed and while the case is high
profile it may not be the only one of
its kind paul whelan a former marine
with canadian british and american
citizenship was taken into russian
custody in 2018. he was subsequently
convicted of espionage and continues to
languish in russia the united states
government at the very highest levels is
working very hard
to bring miss greiner as well as all
wrongfully detained u.s citizens safely
home
but as long as there's no end in sight
to the war in ukraine
it's hard to see any resolution for
those caught in the crossfire
crystal gomansing global news
london
another careless visitor to yellowstone
national park in wyoming is learning
about wildlife the hard way gored by a
bison a 71 year old woman was taken to
hospital with non-life-threatening
injuries after approaching a bison with
her daughter while returning to their
vehicle it's the second bison attack at
the park in just three days and the
park's third attack this year
on monday a bison charged a group of
tourists getting way too close going a
34 year old colorado man who suffered an
arm injury while trying to help a child
the animal was chasing
marking a quarter century under china's
rule
coming up the anxiety over what lies
ahead for hong kong plus
the reunion 45 years in the making no
strings attached
china's president xi jinping was in hong
kong today to celebrate a key
anniversary it's been 25 years since the
former british colony was handed over to
chinese rule back in 1997 the historic
move came with a promise the city state
would remain largely free and
independent of beijing but after years
of often violent crackdowns on freedom
protesters there this anniversary is
anything but a celebration for many
jackson proskow has more
once one of the free societies in asia
hong kong is now firmly under the grasp
of china's authoritarian influence a
city in limbo a shadow of its former
glory i think in my mind that and i
think for many in hong kong this is a
city that is no longer recognizable in
this global financial capital july 1st
had historically been a day for
pro-democracy marches
this year the city was locked down for a
rare visit by chinese president xi
jinping who left mainland china for the
first time since the pandemic to
proclaim hong kong has risen from the
ashes
it is a celebration of the central
government's victory
over the political opposition in hong
kong and the so-called foreign forces in
hong kong
after the british handover in 1997 china
promised hong kong would see 50 years of
independence
instead democratic freedoms have
vanished dissent has been banned we
simply cannot avoid the fact that for
some time now beijing has been failing
to comply with its obligations china
insists no such commitments exist vowing
the promise of one country two systems
still stands even if beijing controls
both those systems most of us were
hoping that hong kong would become more
democratic with time and then maybe even
help lead china towards a more
democratic future instead china's rush
to gain control of hong kong has raised
fears it may soon challenge the
independence of taiwan where local
officials are vowing to fight for their
sovereignty
on the streets of hong kong residents
seem resigned to all they've lost in a
quarter century
the city has changed says this man we
cannot go back
not when freedom has failed to stand the
test of time
jackson proskow global news
i had a very different case of the
mondays why more employers are embracing
the four-day work week
you're watching global national
[Music]
in this competitive labor market nine to
five monday to friday is losing its
appeal a growing number of employers are
trying to embrace the four day work week
and gaviola tells us how it's becoming
an important tool to attract and retain
staff
the monday scaries are a thing of the
past for dozens of municipal workers in
the township of zora in southwestern
ontario they work a four day work week
that extra day just means a world of
difference we've found a more relaxed
atmosphere at work
people seem to be more engaged and it
just seems that our workforce is is
happier
zora trialled compressed work weeks with
some employees getting mondays off
others friday before adopting them for
good at the end of last year researchers
from western and york universities
studied what happened and declared the
experiment a huge success an example of
workplace innovation born in the
pandemic
we just felt that was going to be one
more tool in our toolbox that would help
us not only recruit new employees but
also to retain those key staff members
that we do have
the township fields weekly calls from
municipalities and companies thinking of
adopting four day work weeks too
the compressed work week emerged during
the pandemic as a solution to worker
burnout and an edge in an
ultra-competitive labor market in early
june what's believed to be the biggest
test of the four-day work week began in
the uk 3 300 workers at 70 companies
will try it out for half a year and it
includes a variety of sectors from
retail to software to financial services
square enix montreal has tripled its
workforce over the last three years one
major perk magic mondays employees get
every other monday off most people are
using it
to sort of spread
their
you know chores over three days
to uh to also you know play video games
uh do diys uh just
do things that help them
uh just with uh mental health here's
another one
500 what started out as a lifeline for
working parents juggling working from
home and homeschooling has given the
mobile gaming developer a unique weapon
in the war for talent
as a mother of three it definitely has
been helpful for me to also be able to
cope with this homeschooling and
everything that had to be adapted during
that period
and today it still helps me with the
work life balance who wouldn't want more
long weekends especially in the summer
anne gaviola global news toronto
next after a long pandemic pause how
canadians from coast to coast to coast
are marking the nation's birthday
there's something special about this one
it is the one so
it's just
just
fantastic so cool a long time dream came
true today for canadian rock legend
randy bachman after nearly half a
century of searching he was reunited
with his beloved guitar which had been
stolen from a toronto hotel back in
1976.
the former member of the guess who and
bachmann turner overdrive flew to japan
to reclaim it the guitar had been in the
hands of a tokyo musician who bought it
back in 2014 without knowing its history
well for many communities across this
country canada day is extra special this
year because it's the first time since
2019 most places have been able to hold
festivals and gatherings without coveted
restrictions today there were parades
and parties taking place in every
province and territory as canadians and
visitors celebrated together while
reflecting on the work that still needs
to be done here's heather your ex west
it's been a little while since these
streets hosted a canada day parade i'd
say there's probably a little bit of
rusty and there's a lot of things have
changed over the last couple of years
after a two year pandemic pause
canada day festivities were back across
the country allowing communities to
gather again wearing red and repping the
maple leaf
it's my first ever because we just moved
in here in canada last january we are
very excited and we look forward to more
many years of celebrating canada's day
here it's great just to get together and
that's what it means to me just getting
together
but this day is complicated for many
canadians when i came here first in the
70s
you know canada it was like the land of
opportunity and everything right and as
we go along
over the years we
learn about
you know the history of canada and
everything like that so it's kind of
a kind of dark in the picture of canada
celebrations were muted in 2021
following the discovery of unmarked
graves near the sites of former
residential schools
in edmonton the day was marked with a
reconciliation run i feel like a lot of
people got almost
confused about the celebration of canada
because of the history but i do think
that we can still celebrate
being canadian while still acknowledging
the past in the history
and so we all march forward
celebrating
reflecting on what it means to be
canadian here in canada
on this canada day
heather urex west global news calgary
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm colleen christie we
leave you tonight with more scenes of
the celebrations from our nation's
capital in person for the first time in
two years
thanks for watching and happy canada day
[Music]
you